größtes also feller döner steht wirklich
für qualität er macht zwei verschiedene
brotsorten er steckt ca 400 kilo fleisch
jeden tag wartet das auf offenes feuer
einfach nur pure liebe mein mann ist der
erste gedanke wenn ich ein fahrrad denke
ist dieser döner macht selbst eine
zwiebel zu gold jede komponente
aufeinander abgestimmt und das beste
fleisch was ich je gegessen habe bro
fährt sondern machen viele sachen
besonders aber die hauptsache ist dass
die wichtigste sache nicht in
vergessenheit geraten ist nämlich der
spieß in dem so viel liebe und detail
steckt wie nirgends sonst freunde die
food blogger auf youtube sind sich einig
hinter mir ist der beste trainer der
welt so das kann ich so sagen weil es
sagt weil lukas sagt ich will mich
einfach davon überzeugen ich muss
eigentlich gar nicht irgendetwas großes
ziel ich will einfach nur wissen wie
geil ist dieser döner hier eigentlich
wirklich und lukas war so nett uns ein
intro zu geben der preis bescheid wir
gehen jetzt rein und dann gucken wir
jetzt einfach alles einmal an ich habe
mir extra wenig dazu angeschaut und mich
komplett überraschen zu lassen ich freue
mich sehr darauf der erste blick auf den
döner spieß ist schon endstufe hoch
allein der geruch ganz ganz krank freut
mich sehr eine ihre heimat
was dürfen wir heute erwarten ich also
ich erwarte weil es die ganzen jungs
sagen lukas saarow volle im westen
dünner der welt ja würdest du selbst
auch sagen okay also ich versuche das so
zu machen so gut wie möglich ja klar
versteht wenn man rein schaut dann lässt
das schon wirklich ganz viel erwarten
ihr gerät mit holzkohle als ihr backen
brot selbst gemacht spielte selbst die
form vom spieß ist auch von euch ja
natürlich
ist von a bis z alles okay das hat alles
einen grund dass das spiel sich nicht
trennen aus einem grund ja dahinter
brennt das holz erst gefragt das feuer
und das fleisch gilt dass kate und der
wickelt das und ist das doch durch die
krise ja also dass dieses durch
gegrilltes teilt sieht das vielleicht
nicht noch mal ich bin wirklich schon
innerlich bin schon am strahlend ich
freue mich schon sehr dass das macht mit
dem produkt mit dem döner den ja
wirklich jeder liebt denn jeder markt
werde ich jetzt glaube ich es erst
element werden wenn hier wurde kann ich
auf das büro zeiten ja unbedingt
erkennen können was das wort ankommt
denn wenn wenn man auch normale
betrachtet sieht man ganz normal ist
sicher diese kleine kleine großen würden
so pletz die nacht nicht länger als drei
jahre also von außen ist das zu dürfen
kannst du das sehen ja total extrem also
von außen ist es günstig ja ja und wenn
sie eine miete auf journalist wie milch
brot sind jetzt schon bisher aber dazu
machen nicht wäre
wenn es über spricht sagst du stolz
darauf ist glaubt bekannten auch absolut
seien ja ja so was du gerade gesagt hast
dass du musst dass du dich schwer zu
zweit oder standorte zu eröffnen das
zeigt dass es wirklich einfach nur aus
passion aus liebe jetzt danach in kiel
mit dem land urlaub mit der ganzen
werbung die auch die anderen jungs schon
gemacht haben konzerne kette ja aber ich
mach mir geht es nicht ums geld ja mir
geht das niemals musste ich finde es
jeden zeigen gutes wissen brauchst du
die natürliche zutaten ja jedes mal wenn
wir hier kommt auf deutschland
in deutschland gibt es wie viel der
gastronom hunderttausende von jedem
verkauf millionen kunden ja es muss
ehrlich seines kurses wirklich natürlich
ist etwas an das möchte ich ihr zeigen
und ich möchte dass man mir nach macht
ja ich könnte dir stundenlang zuhören
ich will aber deine zeit gar nicht
weiter in anspruch nehmen und ich will
vor allem den döner essen
[Musik]
halten
und genauso wird zu machen ja sogar mehr
[Musik]
endstufe
die mädels haben schon probiert endstufe
euch gehört und ja mit soße genommen ich
bin wirklich sehr sehr gespannt du weißt
gar nicht richtig freuen sich wenn ich
weiß ich gerade fühle ich mich noch
nicht mal so breit da jetzt rein
nachdem entrup genau ich glaube es gibt
nur einen weg herauszufinden wie gut
dieser
die kamera ist so sagt er
war also erster punkt werden meinte wenn
man rein weist muss knusprig das ist so
dieses knußmann was schon so spaß macht
ist das knusperhaus trotzdem chips ist
wenn du so richtig knusprig zitierte
pommes ist das einfach so ein ding so
macht jetzt schon spaß den zu essen und
text dass das so klappt ohne dass es
vorher nochmal in so einem kontakt
gelegt wurde oder sondern auch und
bröseln und es ist einfach perfekt und
das ist so der erst also nur der pfanne
asbeck aber so das fleisch hat so eine
würze so eine konsistenz ist hier noch
mal ganz kurz auf rindfleisch 100% salat
tomate zwiebel und ein ganz bisschen
petersilie mehr ist da nicht drin aus
kassel
wie ist der grip flavour wir waren
gerade beide da vorne ist verdammt heiß
ist der geschmack von fleisch vom
fleische ist wirklich witzig aber du
kannst das nicht von düngern das fleisch
so präsent so definiert sondern fleisch
schmeckt weil du was häufig auf dem
grill schließen wahrscheinlich nicht die
fall nicht also hast du nicht die
qualität die du hier hast kollegen bei
uns wird ja auch 90 prozent nur halb
oder lamm verwendet wann wird mal 100
prozent rindfleisch verwendet bei uns ja
ich will bildet die auch so geil dass
ich jetzt eigentlich habe ich würde
sagen das so anders gedacht ist so von a
bis z alles gedacht aber theater habt
ihr selbst gesagt es wurde sich vielmehr
so an die ursprünge zurück erinnert ist
das erst mal das
kloster qualität besser wird die
qualität checken das schmeckt wie wenn
ich mir unsere progress spaß beim essen
du hast einen wahnsinnig besonderen
geschmack einen wahnsinnig guten
geschmack und das weiß ich jetzt selbst
war nichts zu sagen erzählte fühlt sich
danach voraussichtlich auch noch gut ja
weil jetzt mal ganz ehrlich was soll
daran dir nicht gut tun du hast keine
fertige joghurt soße du hast du keinen
scheiß drinnen auf gut deutsch gesagt
jetzt mal ernst was ist daran scheiße
das wird besser nicht
das wort das wir drin wird das ist
richtig ich bin jetzt aber ist einfach
noch mal so zwei drei mal rein genieße
es einfach in die gastfreundschaft
natürlich auch eine große rolle wie
möglich und so lieb empfangen ihr penis
immer ein bisschen für dich ja muss
machen und daneben werden heute drei mit
so seine position asse die prinzessin
ich will nur noch
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
wir sind
angekommen ja ich will dich
zu gehören weil es schon n also wirklich
ist krass ok du weißt nicht ich bin ja
ihr könnt leider nicht sehen
wann kommt ein video dauert ein bisschen
ende ließ doch ende nächster woche dann
könnt ihr sehen ich werde jetzt schon
sehen aber in dem moment von reinweißen
will ich
bin so aufgeregt okay let's go
leute
sind so feierabend zwei stück gegessen
und das stimmt könnte mir nicht
vorstellen wie sehr es stimmt dass du
dich nach dem essen fraser brooke fühlt
sich dies nicht erschlagen ist einfach
qualität und es spielt so gut vor allen
dingen nicht nur so körperlich sondern
auch seelisch sexy ja für uns vor allem
weil wir jetzt diese tolle erfahrung
hatten ihr habt ja auch mitbekommen
zumindest den aspekt solltet ihr auch
gut übermittelt bekommen haben wie die
idee dahinter steckt so was dass eine
passion ist und so das hat uns wirklich
die ganze zeit über eigentlich darüber
gesprochen an den francesco erinnert an
den pizza weltmeister francesco dazu
weil der hat genau so eine stolz
geschwellte brust wert ist genauso stolz
auf seine burg der weiß was er gut macht
der brend dafür und das leuchten im
auggener erweist ich zeige gerade etwas
wofür ich stehe das ist einfach es also
es lohnt sich hier für nach wien zu
kommen wo man muss gar nichts anders
anschauen
feier
richtig gut